Hi, I'm Faye de Muyshondt with Socialsklz,...
...here to teach you the difference between a formal and an informal email.
While I was teaching at New York University,...
...I realized it was an extremely important lesson...
...to talk to my students about what constitutes a formal versus an informal email...
...and when we should and shouldn't use formal emails, when we are reaching out to people.
When you write a formal email, think about writing a formal letter to someone.
So, you want to use the salutation dear so-and-so if it's a professor...
...or if it's someone with a special title, you'd want to use those special titles...
...and as you write the email, it should be in proper paragraph form,...
...there should be no abbreviations at all whatsoever.
The body of the email should be written really well,...
...just as you would write a letter to someone like I said.
So, there shouldn't be any abbreviations, no slang, no acronyms...
...and as you finish your email,...
...you want to make sure that you properly sign off with your first and your last name.